[Music]
you seem like you're very knowledgeable
about the internet you're very good at
sending out photographs and you sort of
seem to know the whole culture lovely
yes you you do selfies which I can't
believe well there is there's a thing
called the selfie but I wonderful I feel
so proud when you come up with something
original he was backstage and I wanted
to do a selfie with him then I came up I
said I want to do something better than
the selfie so I did a selfish she asked
yeah what a selfish a selfish she but I
let him be the star of The Selfish Gene
this is the first sofa she in they've
never been that's never been done with
to anywhere anywhere with two
celebrities let's now unveil which we
show it now yes at first sofa she ever
with two celebrities in it there we are
[Applause]
if you have a good selfish if you start
doing them yeah
send them in we'll make a book of self
we'll make a book of suffices that's
fantastic
what could we put our name together on
the book yeah now that I see yeah
Conan Reiner and call Conan Reiner yeah
listen I would be honored if your name
went first but I want a copy of the
whole book okay
I don't want one page
you